ap
signature est une écurie basée à bourges
qui joue dans l'antichambre de là f1
formule 3 euro séries depuis 93 cette
écurie française se fait
pour ses qualités de gestion sportive
mais aussi pour la véritable pépinière
de jeunes pilotes dont certains seront
demain dans le circuit mondial
le mans un nom mythique la seule épreuve
française pour le challenge f3 euro
séries quatre voitures des dallara à
moteur mercedes
quatre pilotes guillaume romain grosjean
charlie kimball des teams stand deux
courses pour marquer des points c'est
l'avant-dernier week-end de là
pour romain grosjean dont l'avenir est
prometteur il a un gros coeur surtout
premier virage dans cette compétition
pas de cadeau
[Musique]
je me retrouve en tête à l'attaqué du
premier virage et puis là
malheureusement l'histoire en a décidé
autrement on va dire que je me suis fait
shooter donc d'accord c'est fini là je
me disais qu'en étendant les trois
premiers les autres en auront un cerveau
et qu' il y aurait pas de problème
malheureusement ça s'est passé comme ça
et j'en veux beaucoup au pilote machete
maidens soir en sommet dimanche matin
deuxième loi pour le team manager à une
course de la fin de la saison c'est déjà
dormir
c'est important pour nous de faire un
bon résultat qui plus est on court après
de bons résultats depuis la mi-saison
donc ça vient en ponctuant et être
récompensé les efforts qu'on a pu faire
ces dernières semaines pour améliorer
voiture et et au mans c est un grand
plaisir de renouer avec le podium
résultats du week-end deux podiums pour
les pilotes signature dans une semaine
rendez vous en allemagne
[Musique]